when you put together this technological
revolution and a government mentality
that says we will do anything it takes
to stop terrorism what you have is
dangerous hi I'm Paul teacher caprice on
TV today we're talking with Adam
Schwartz of the ECL you in Illinois
we're going to talk about fusion centers
and stalking us out of pleasure to be
talking to you for those out there that
don't know what fusion centers are could
you just give us a brief description
sure in the wake of the 911 terror
attacks the US government has spent
billions of dollars to have the US
Department of Homeland Security Fund
state and local fusion centers these are
state organizations that fuse under one
roof as much information as possible
about people who are suspected of
criminal or terrorist and then they
funnel this information towards the
Department of Homeland Security and what
kind of information are we talking about
here well if a person is of interest to
the Illinois fusion center the Illinois
fusion center has access to a vast
number of databases about that person
including criminal databases run by
every level of government including
non-criminal government databases such
as head shots in the Secretary of
State's database the Illinois fusion
center also has access to private
databases and so they know about
everybody's business licenses their
employment history the identities of
their neighbors and relatives what
property they own what is the ACL u--'s
perspective on this what's the danger of
these fusion centers the first concern
is that a person might become the object
of fusion center scrutiny for no good
reason so for example the missouri
fusion center published report saying
that the followers of ron paul and the
people who display flags and say don't
tread on me might be involved in
domestic terrorism and not to be
scrutinized by american law enforcement
or for example the Virginia fusion
center published report concluding that
historically black colleges and
universities were nodes of radicalism
that should be under law enforcement
scrutiny in Maryland the future
center with scrutinizing opponents of
the death penalty law enforcement is
taking in all of this information
doesn't that lead to stopping crime
there is a recently published report by
the United States Senate bipartisan
report which examined what the US
government has been getting for its
money billions of dollars that has
channeled through the Department of
Homeland Security to the 70 or so state
and local fusion centers in America and
what this report concludes based on
reviewing hundreds and hundreds of the
reports coming from the fusion centers
to the Homeland Security Department is
that these reports are doing nothing to
protect us from terrorism that the
reports contain old information or
already published information or
information unrelated to terrorism and
perhaps of greatest concern to the sou
information that would violate the
Federal Privacy Act prohibition on the
federal government's collecting
information about people's First
Amendment activities in the absence of
suspicion of a crime is it possible for
viewers to look up the information that
a fusion center might have about them
there are safeguards that we think every
fusion sensor should have and one of
them is that people should be able to
find out whether or not the fusion
center has a file on them and if so to
get the file and to be able to petition
the fusion center to remove information
that they think is not correct and if
the fusion center refuses to do so to be
able to put their own statement into the
file that explains what they think is
wrong so that you know later on when
someone else in the law enforcement
community gets the file they can see the
person's rebuttal we are in the midst of
a technological revolution which
empowers the government in a way that
never previously existed to track what
innocent Americans are doing and to use
that information against us and in the
wake of the 911 terror attacks the
expectation for many people as the
government should use as many of these
new technologies as possible to do
everything possible to keep us as safe
as possible and when you put these two
things together all of our privacy and
all of our civil liberties is managed is
there any way of going back or is this
here to stay you know I think the
technological revolution obviously
cannot be prevented and it should not be
prevented by government from the view of
the ACLU there are many pro civil
liberties aspects of the technological
revolution but when you put together
this
technological revolution on the one hand
and a government mentality that says we
will do anything it takes to stop
terrorism or the possibility of
terrorism what you have is dangerous and
so really the first question ought to be
whenever the government proposes one of
these new technologies will the use of
this technology actually make us safer